welcome to this video playing em western
a tough opponent 16 games played and I
one plus one sorry for the sounds we're
requesting for this game I tried to eat
a little snag it and the game popped up
okay so we get as a mish check I wonder
what my score this opening us in in
those blitz games hmm really no idea I
have won by a fair share of interesting
games but I also lost a ton so what what
is clear however that the draw rate is
really low maybe if over here okay I
wonder if Queenie two or something as an
idea to trying to i might play for some
d5 ok there three this should be seven
it's not the ideal place for that Bishop
though it usually wants to go to a six I
mean this is not terrible for black or
so but it's not so common so he allows
me that depend I really amazed how many
good players high rated players allow
that pin it is just really just a
mistake not more not less I came
and again therefore we had this we had
this early mf4 TX pin night x g5 night
h5 night h5 Queen h5 GH 45 ok not sure
this so convincing
f-for takes 90 x g5 maybe 'if I've tu
five-night age 59 age 52 instincts yeah
come on it's a sir this is in the spirit
of this line so not hesitating here this
is you just have to fire here and the
sameish anything else's and everything
else is just wrong so let's see Knight
takes Queen takes gtx age for Queen age
six should win normally I mean he can do
he can do other things 97 or so but I
will always have a pretty
dangerous-looking attack yeah i was
thinking Queen g4 may be threatening
queen tier covering this once you for
and what's so ready for Queen f5 yeah it
would be weird if it's not a good move
honey maybe Bishop c8 Bishop see aid I
can go Queenie for you anyway Queenie 4f
525 I don't really think that taking
this Bishop there can be the the issue
with with the with this line and Bishop
c8 i can go Bishop f5 just just
attacking without sacrificing the house
hmm
Queenie for f5 queen e 5g takes H form
that looks terrible already but that
also looks good not sure this is not so
powerful as Queenie forward it might
still be okay
so more now just look everyone piling up
probably up everything trying for
maximum firepower so I can take on g5
Bishop takes pawn takes rook takes pawn
takes Queenie sex check wins okay check
check yeah these games make the zimage
fun sometimes you get get just crushed
strategically because you you are really
playing a risky opening but sometimes
you get those games but before I'm
celebrating I should find the maid first
where is the mate not seeing it yet
Queen g8 conjugate check and check no
mate do I really have to go g4 and
prepare for that made ugh check king
queen age seven though check taking ages
here to find this but it does win
you
Queen age seven Chang Qing g4 hmm check
that looks funny really and Kings you
for wasting made check some g3 it's
funny can I go King age 24 g three yeah
I can go like that and there's Nigeria
also in black resigns ok yeah that's uh
that was a famous game out of the
textbook ok they are 98 you you simply I
think you have to avoid the pin it's
just so awful I think I really should
have avoided that ok five yeah I know
this F for business there's that motif
we had in countless games it is very
dangerous at least somewhat is TX and
now I pushed a five yes and it's tangent
move great so I got that one right yeah
I wasn't so convinced by this I wasn't
so convinced here to be honest okay well
the engine gives us as good as well I
wasn't completely sure if I'm winning
here a 35 might win but this seems to
win as well yeah okay I have this sorry
rook f5 g5 as well yeah I wasn't sure
about this but it seems to be good as
well this is what the engine gives and
then dropping back
Magister great position I mean I Lucy
forward the whole King side is right is
a wreck but that shouldn't be bad should
be a good compensation this looks kind
of normal even though Queenie to other
Musa seemed good as well yet here I
wasn't sure Bishop f5 was there was the
simple simple move let's say did this
sorry I'm this also was interesting f
five th stings but here I couldn't find
I didn't see a good good reply I somehow
don't get here like some check on g3
would be good but there's a pawn and I
don't have a great continuation engine
disagree minus two so it was okay here
yeah maybe yes to go f6 first awesome
Bishop a success given by the engine
that's a that's very cool 10 night b7
job tough but here he is lost him is
really directly lost look f1 minus 3y
cannot prevent those sacrifices and
check check check check the quickest
made his chief FOIA besides is also made
right check I our queen d3 is quicker
threatening Queen h3 check that's made
next move check IL it's also a major
checkmate not bad but okay I found one
and I'm glad throughout having found
having fun oneness is enough okay thanks
for watching